hello i'm now going to use the actual
khan academy website to uh do some more
problems and this time we're going to go
the other way around we're going to look
at a trigonometric
the graph of a trigonometric function
and we're going to try to figure out the
equation so let's start with the problem
we have in front of us so we have a well
we don't know if it's a sine curve or
cosine curve but i guess it's it's fair
to say that it's it's one of the two
so actually let's answer that question
first what do you think this is do you
think that this is a sine curve or a
cosine curve
well what do we know what's the
difference or what's the easiest
difference to uh differentiate between
the two
well what was sine of zero and let me
let me get a little chalkboard in here
let me bring it right here
what is
let me make sure my pen tool is correct
all right
right here what is sine of 0
sine of 0 and it could be 0 degrees or z
or radians if you remember from a couple
of the other modules or even if you want
to use the calculator sine of zero is
zero
and what is cosine of zero
well cosine of zero if if you remember
from the last modules or you want to use
a calculator although you shouldn't have
to use a calculator for cosine of 0 you
might remember it was 1.
so this graph that we have here
it's definitely
when when
x
is 0 when the x-axis is zero
the function definitely isn't zero in
fact in this case it's one and a half
so this tells us that this isn't a sine
curve although later with shifts we'll
learn that it could be a shifted sine
curve that this isn't a sine curve that
this is a cosine curve and then you
might ask well sal if this is a cosine
curve why does this inner why is f of
zero equal to one and a half or three
halves instead of one because i just
i just said here that cosine of zero is
one well that's because
there must be some type of a coefficient
here
let's call it a
that is changing the amplitude of this
cosine curve and if you remember from
the last module
what do you think this a is well that a
is just literally the amplitude of the
curve and what's the amplitude of this
curve
well the amplitude of this curve if we
just uh
see how much it moves above and below
the x-axis well it's it's that
three-halves or that one-and-a-half
we've been talking about see it moves up
three and a half and it moves down three
and a half
so let me just write that so we know
that this is
that this is three
halves
cosine
of
well something x right
we know f of x is equal to three halves
cosine of something x and we could use
the formula
that we learned in the previous
video that it equals two pi over the
period
x so now we just have to look at the
graph and try to figure out what the
period of the graph is
well how many radians does it take for
the graph to start repeating again
let me click on the hint button and
maybe this will help us
when i click hint there drew the period
and you could have figured it out on
your own if you just go from um any uh
point and then go follow the curve back
to the same point again
you'll see how long its period is and
the hint on the khan academy actually
told us that the period is four pi and
you could have started from any point to
the other point you could have gone from
this point and then gone down gone back
up come down and then you would have
seen that this distance is also four pi
so we know that the period is four pi
and i can click hint again and it'll
tell us stuff that we already figured
out
the amplitude we already figured out was
one and a half
but let's let's just use the period
because we already knew what the
amplitude is so the the period here we
already figured out was four pi so let's
just write that in our equation so
f of x
is equal to
three halves
cosine
of two pi
divided by the period the period in this
case is four pi
x
that equals
three halves
cosine
one half
x
now if you ever forget this formula
which frankly i always do forget it i've
actually never memorized it i just try
to think about what the period would be
the way i think about it is
the coefficient on the x term that's a
measure of how many how many cycles
does
the graph do
within 2 pi radians
let me let me see if i can explain that
within the context of this problem so
this problem
if we
if we start at 0 and then 2 pi is here
how many cycles do we complete by the
time we get to 2 pi we start here
we go back here and then we're at 2 pi
well we only got halfway done through a
cycle so that's the coefficient on the x
term that's how i remember it
so i could just say well that's three
halves
cosine
of how many cycles do i complete in two
pi radians well i only complete half a
cycle
three halves times the cosine of one
half x so that's our f of x
let's do another problem
all right okay this one's interesting so
the first thing just by just by
inspection we can figure out what this
amplitude is this is pretty easy right
how much does it move above and below
the x-axis
well it only goes one so we know that
the coefficient on or the the multiplier
times the sine or the cosine function
whichever this is is one so let's write
that down
let's write down that
the amplitude
amplitude
is equal to 1. now let's try to figure
out if this is a sine or cosine function
and the last problem we saw
we we said well it's it's either going
to be
it's if if it's
sine of 0 is 0 and cosine of 0 is 1
well f of 0 of this function whichever
it is is 0. so we know this is a this is
a non-shifted
sine function so there let's we have
another piece of information it's a sine
function
it's a sine function
so the last thing we have to figure out
we could either figure out the period or
we could use
the method that i just showed you where
we say well how many times
does it cycle
within 2 pi radians so let's do it that
way and then we immediately know the
coefficient let's see it goes
well actually this graph board doesn't
even get all the way to 2 pi but let's
see it goes
one cycle
two cycles and i did two cycles and only
pi radians right because i'm only at x
equals pi here so if i did two cycles
and pi radians then we must be able to
do four cycles in two pi radians or we
could we could actually start here
actually this is better right going from
negative pi to pi that's two pi radians
so we finish one cycle
two cycles
three cycles four cycles so then we know
what the coefficient of the x term is
so we know there's sine of 4x so the
answer here is f of x
is equal to 1 because that's the
amplitude the amplitude which is just 1
times sine
before x i think we have time for one
more
and i want you to
don't don't just you know mechanically
do whatever i'm telling i want you to
think about why counting the number of
cycles within two pi radians why that
makes sense to you then think back to
the unit circle or think about why that
formula that you know the the the 2 pi
divided by the period is also the
coefficient think about why that makes
sense it's if you if you realize why it
makes sense you'll never have to
memorize it and then 20 years later when
you're doing it like i'm doing it right
now
you won't be confused you'll be able to
rederive the formulas let's do one more
all right
so what's the amplitude here well let's
see the amplitude
is one half let me let me delete the old
stuff that i was writing before
for some reason it's not deleting
okay
hope it doesn't confuse you so the
amplitude let's just call it a amplitude
is equal to one-half
and
how many cycles does it complete within
2 pi radians
let's see
it goes if we start here
it looks like it completes only half a
cycle right because it takes four pi
radians to complete two to complete the
entire cycle so it only completes half a
cycle
so we could say well we could think of
it either two ways we could say that the
the period
is equal to 4 pi because that's how long
it takes to complete one cycle or we
could say it can only complete half a
cycle in
within 2 pi radians
the last thing we have to figure out is
the sine or cosine function well
f of 0 is 0 right so it's a non-shifted
sine function so then we're done we have
f of x
is equal to
one half
figured out it's a sine function
sine
of what
how many cycles did it complete in
two pi radians it only completed half a
cycle let me
not cover the problem it only completes
half a cycle so it's one half sine of
one half x or we could use the formula
f of x equals one half sine of two pi
divided by the period x right because
two pi divided by
the period is equal to 2 pi
over 4 pi
which also equals one-half
i think that'll give you a sense of how
to do these problems now
and i encourage you to practice them on
the khan academy
website have fun